you know i've been on the same tour for
this hour for almost over a year now
um dude bands tour for like four years
and then [ __ ] go right back in the
studio make another one and keep going
you got to toughen up man yeah you're
right huh
yeah what do i do camouflage hat looking
like a [ __ ] backwoods guy all tough
and [ __ ] you can't handle
doing your hour again i mean come on man
suck it up
really is that is that you in action or
is this another photoshop
yeah it's a photo shoot people do photo
shoots yeah i know have you ever seen
like a movie poster and you'll see a
movie star
he's clearly five foot two yet somehow
he's as tall as the super have
i have yeah that's that's a photo shoot
no fix stuff
look i'm sorry you're just on the web
man
you you took it this he took it to this
place i'm not trying to [ __ ] on his
website
what is it called again huh
zippitydoodah.com
you got it huh you [ __ ] you have
me on your show when you start trashing
my dvd
you're a sensitive man bill thanks so
much for being here i love this show
you're one of my favorite comedians i'm
excited to talk to you
well i'm excited to be here these chairs
are horrific
this is like this is designed for like i
don't know what age
it's not like six to eight like when
you're 11 this is like the perfect size
it's not quite adult size it's not kid's
size
i already slouched it's gonna be a bad
interview dude and i'm blaming the chair
i slouch or go down like this or
all right cross the legs uh bill you're
are you the head writer on the show or
how do you how do you work in the
writer's room on the show cause you
write your stand-up specials you know
obviously you're a writer but
you've never really written on a sitcom
before if you go through your credits
you hadn't really been on the show
before
why'd you have to bring that up just
right out of the gate it goes negative
never really saw you right on anything
before bill um
there was all these other nice things on
your imdb page i could have brought up
but i noticed this one
glaring thing that you've never done and
right out of the gate was it because i
made fun of
the chairs i'm sorry here in the emily
fan cave hanging out with active
comedian bill burke i like that you said
actor comedian
well you're right as dude if you saw my
imdb page you definitely know it was uh
a comedian actor yeah it's a quick read
but i think i have like a thing
yeah it's like i don't like i have a
tough time
working i just think i have a tough time
working with other people sometimes you
know which is one of the reasons why i
got into comedy anyway
you know what this is i would say get
over that yeah
get over yourself and get over that
because there's a lot of great people in
this business and you're gonna miss out
and uh i don't know
what you'll say your loved ones will
save money on the funeral costs because
no one's gonna go so there's not gonna
be too many [ __ ] snacks they gotta
put together
you're one of those guys you don't need
compliments you actually need to be
pulled down
yes be tethered i give myself to
something and i would say that it it
it betrays an underlying insecurity but
there isn't with you you're just full
on [ __ ] ego i love it jesse
uh you did so bad one of our guests is
about to quit uh
i don't know what else to talk oh if
there's a negative lining
tony will find it there it is right
between the ray of sunshine
is that little nugget of negativity you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] smarmy [ __ ]
[ __ ] jesus christ if we went to a movie
together would we sit next to each other
would you want a seat between us
you know oh jesus cause that's a tough i
want to sit like nine rows behind you
and
just tug on your ponytail you savage
that's what i would do
oh from flannel underscore toilet
semicolon um
when is do you think moonshine will make
it
make their big comeback moon shoes
i i can't read by the way when is do you
think moon shoes
will make their big comeback what are
what are moon shoes
it's like trampolines on your feet just
sometimes you're bouncing around like
you're on the moon
i didn't know that they ever had them
flannel toilet i had no idea um
so but i had to guess when did they come
up
yeah does anybody [ __ ] know jesus
christ yeah at some point i was gonna
make a point here that's why i keep
looking at here and i just realized i'm
blocking myself out of the camera i love
that you have the jib camera for this
like it's an action movie
let's let's let's swoop in at these two
guys sitting in these unbelievably
small chairs i literally feel like i'm
gonna fall onto the floor this is insane
you really went all out with the
audience though they got full-sized
adult chairs
are these like from the 20s before they
had like horse tranquilizers in our food
when everybody was like five foot one
it's funny when you said we when i'm
like did we really win but i don't know
what you're saying i understand what
you're saying
now is that that african-american thing
yeah
i don't want to alarm you but i don't
think that that little life jacket that
they gave you was designed for someone
your size
yeah we'll see man i don't think it's a
it'll support 315 pounds but uh let's
hope for the best
come on dwayne you got this
there you go yes sir
[Music]
talking to a seahawk fan here now is it
true the rumor is that you guys
aren't as loud as they say that they
actually designed the stadium
to contain it
sounds like a pigeon you don't get drunk
when your kid's around my [ __ ] lou
grant with a bottle of whiskey in the
remember that in mary tyler moore's show
she'd have a rough day and she'd come in
and i don't remember the whole show i
can explain it to you
yeah if i can explain it like a guy just
i don't know what that is all right i
don't know i don't know and the second i
started to explain like i don't know the
whole show all right
i get it i get it i believe that comic
add like i don't even [ __ ]
i'm not into it i don't want to hear it
i got it your show go ahead continue
i remember uh all right let's talk about
old shows then we don't have to
i just was it was a funny how you
[ __ ] you bailed twice on that
patty duke made me feel like an [ __ ]
like that was the 15th time i [ __ ]
brought it up
sorry no mary tyler moore
[Music]
steve and this is southside steve tv
and this is bill burr that's your
question
i'm just saying who you are oh yeah all
right i don't like you creeped me out
with that big microphone in that country
western shirt
oh no this isn't country western it's
like it's hip now to wear this
this is my nightclub look yeah come on
all right yo your uh what is this rock
101.5
this is the worst interview i've ever
done and he's wearing stetson cologne or
something
it's just really over overpowering
you know what he looks like he looks
like the first guy who gets his ass
kicked in a steven seagal movie
the background guy behind the uh the big
kingpin wouldn't you handle this
where are you guys from you live here
how the hell did you end up here
long story shifty felonies yes is that a
rolex
yes it is i finally bought one 25 years
in this business is it white gold or
stainless
i don't know what it is is it heavy no
then it's stainless
oh is that what it is thank you thank
you for taking my watch down a notch
i finally felt successful you see this
you wouldn't say that if i had brown or
black hair i guarantee you
blonde hair you'd be over here giving me
your watch
this is the only way you can be
comfortable in these [ __ ] chairs this
is like in the middle of my back
oh my god i love you but i hate this set
this is the lowest budget [ __ ] you know
it is it's the rent
it's the [ __ ] rent you did all this
stuff you should get rid of that camera
and get some chairs
what what kind of chair would you prefer
comfortable adult-sized
chair you want me to be a soft uh you
know
you know one of those twitter tough guys
when guys come and sit on the couch i go
right after him don't you respect me for
that no i don't
your big dumb desk hiding behind your
microphone thank you for keeping it real
college yeah i kept it a hundred
but when you kill somebody out and then
have them in front of you that's punk
no but then you can actually just admit
that you're wrong when the guy's
delivering because now he's delivering
he's still trying oh yeah he's not
admitting that he's wrong
i remember listening to uh george
michael on the school bus when i would
go to school
and i felt like and i would always sit
by myself do you feel like you were
going to catch aids
by doing that some sort of airborne hiv
through the [ __ ] radio
i mean bro i was holding it up to my ear
you know
radio aids was going to get me
come over here somebody hold the camera
jump in yeah
here we go in the middle get in the
middle two studs here comes here comes
home school look he's got on buckle
shoes i know
i bet he made those he went to one of
those little house in the prairie
schools where like the person next to
you was eight years older but you were
still in the same grade
i got to tell you the laker fans are
even worse i can't stand them at least
yankee fans show up at the start of the
game those laker friends they show up in
like the second quarter
they had to get like botox before they
came down to the game oh no
ouch but you like living in l.a i love
yeah i love la and i also love i like
living there i don't like their teams
i hate the jets i'm sick of people
saying i'm sick of people saying rex
ryan is confident he's not confident
that guy cries himself to sleep with a
vata ice cream every night
i'm not buying it i'm not you know what
i because the older guys
robert kelly's and all they all call you
billy colin calls you billy
but i [ __ ] bill i'm just immediately
noticing that
i don't know about the chain if it's if
it's thick enough to be
that one that level of confidence yeah
well it's more
well i just hate the jets straight up
being a patriots fan i hate their whole
slogan
play like a jet play like a jet why
would you say that
they haven't won in like 50 years why
don't you play like a patriot
or a steeler player and that's stupid
that fireman who gets on his boyfriend's
shoulder like he's
like it's some hot chick at a bon jovi
concert